the dr. Phil's story Matt isn't angry or
mad isn't crazy yes you know if Mickey
didn't finish off that bottle of bourbon
he might realize there's a hurricane
outside what's that boy a sharknado well
he's no longer a planet so who gives a
[Music]
if he's gonna experiment on Pluto there
will be answers judging by these
footprints I deduce he has feet welcome
to Castlevania dr. xxx next on cinema
snob the first porno starring cartoon
dogs well it's nice of that bridge to
politely collapse yeah we want to kill
you but kill you with kindness it's like
the welcome mat it's deep van it's house
you now belong to the Disney Vault wrong
the treat survivors seeking revenge on
mystery Inc the nearsighted ghoul had no
idea this wasn't scooby-doo coming this
summer Walt Disney's doomed 64
[Music]
the lakes of Gwendoline Christie
foreshadow Mickey's end okay guys I know
it's the 30s Python would be able to do
better than this Mickey has a match
Disney was a smoker so Mickey as a
smoker at the sound of the tone it would
be difficult I don't have any lungs or
lips but take this oh it's the newest
reality show
practical jokes insane Raimi Babu damn
it Frank piss off you know I get the dog
I'm just not for the life of me
understanding the chicken so this is how
chick-fil-a comes up with their sandwich
ideas and no
good god the dog wills your junk I
splice you Gundam style I guess it was
pretty funny seriously you should get
that looked at I am a doctor you know
[Music]
humans sent a deed for kids yeah you
know I got to hand it to him that
science seems pretty legit
[Music]
yikes pop Barker was right spade and
neuter folks H P Lovecraft's mousetrap
it's a scariest game for ages three to
the grave free hugs
I thought we had something
[Music]
we just saw transformers five heads up
cooperhog hats well roll hood poor damn
it Frank
[Music]
sorry 'its I think this is what
Jehovah's Witnesses wish they could do
at every door
Oh II love have you lost weight
[Music]
this is actually what Sam Raimi's
spider-man 4 was gonna look like must
have gotten him in the funny bone I have
no brother
eat my ass oh god a baby bitch from hell
that very specifically sounds like
gluten shadow being cut in half jesus
tapdancing christ I can't even who does
this why have six doors if only the last
ones locked this is some goofy crap
right here no this was your last episode
Oh another proud volunteer to watch the
emoji movie it's like a salon run by
Morticia Addams
sorry I was thinking of Jacque from Big
Bang Theory that's how you know I'm evil
apparently Mickey's a little dusty in
the groin old apartment Minnie has a lot
of headaches Bugs Bunny says Merry
Christmas you little
you expect me to talk no mr. Mouse I
expect you to squeak
[Music]
see kids this is what happens when you
eat at Arby's before bedtime but they
have the maids
holy crap that was way worse the Donalds
dream about becoming a nazi hey kids
what have we learned today that a story
about a boy and his dog can be made
better with buzzsaws skeletons and a
creepy scientist who makes the marquis
de sade Lister Rogers you might be
wondering where many was in all of this
she was the doctor's first victim
[Music]
you